President Trump says he might want to
end birthright citizenship by executive
order we investigate the nature of
anti-semitism and we talk about the
relationship between rhetoric and
violence I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show so every day a new news
cycle there's a lot to talk about today
as well
still more news in the aftermath of the
pittsburgh synagogue shooting plus the
President of the United States has now
unleashed a new controversy he says that
he might want to sign an executive order
getting rid of birthright citizenship
for the children of illegal immigrants
will talk about the legality of that and
the policy considerations and what this
has to do with the 2018 elections but
first let's talk about managing your
money so as a human who does not have
tons of time to manage my own money I
have advisers who tell me how to manage
my money for me and you know I'll tell
you it's kind of expensive but the
reality is you don't need a really
expensive financial adviser what you
really need is somebody who's gonna help
you outsmart average and that's where
betterment comes in betterment is the
smart way to manage your money it's the
investing tools for people who refuse to
settle for average investing it's
cutting-edge technology combined with
human expertise here's what it does it's
technology designed to help you make
more from your investments unlimited
expert advice designed to help you make
smart financial decisions you know time
to read all the prospectus says you can
you need somebody helping you out and
this is what betterment does they give
you tax efficient investing strategies
that give you an edge with low
transparent fees constant access to
information tools that allow you to
track progress toward your goals so you
can always feel like a smart savvy
investor sign up today get up to one
year manage for free betterment helps
you outsmart average investing does
involve risk the Ben Shapiro show
listeners can get up to one year manage
for free for more information visit
better mint.com slash Shapiro that's
betterment comm slash appear you owe it
to yourself to invest your money the
smart way betterment helps you outsmart
average betterment comm slash Shapiro
sitting up to one-year manage for free
so check it out right now all right so
the big controversy of the day because
every day a new controversy that's the
theme of today is America the President
of the United States has now said in an
interview that he is interested in
signing an executive order that would
end birthright citizenship for illegal
immigrant children so here is the way
the law currently operates if you come
to the United States for virtually any
purpose unless you are a foreign
diplomat you come to the United States
and you have a baby in the United States
that baby is autumn
matically a citizen of the united states
entitled to all rights and privileges
conferred upon all citizens of the
United States the reason that this is a
controversial issue is because nothing
in the Constitution actually says that
this is the case not only does nothing
in the Constitution actually say that
this is the case there's pretty good
evidence that the framers of the
Fourteenth Amendment had no intent to do
anything remotely like this suggests
that just because you come to the United
States and then you have a baby here
your baby is now a United States citizen
and this does have some pretty
significant costs involved right now you
have in California seen many stories
about this you've had situations where
legitimate birth tourism is happening
people are traveling to the United
States just to have babies in the United
States so that their kids become
American citizens and there's some
pretty significant impacts the Center
for Immigration Studies which is very
anti illegal immigration and they
estimate that between 300 and 400
thousand children are born to illegal
immigrants in the United States every
single year meaning one out of every ten
births in the United States is to any
legal immigrant mother all of those
children are considered by the executive
branch of the US government to be US
citizens enjoying the same rights and
privileges as the children of US
citizens the population of us born
children with illegal alien parents has
expanded rapidly from 2.3 million in
2003 to 4 million in 2008 and that does
not include children who are 18 years of
age or older so the actual figure is
actually somewhat larger all of the
benefits that are available to American
citizens are obviously available to
these American citizens there's a lot of
talk about illegal immigration not
having a tremendous impact on the
American economy because he legal
immigrants are barred from federal
welfare for example their children
however are not and this does lead to
chain migration because children are now
US citizens and they can sponsor their
parents for a United States Citizenship
the Center for Immigration Studies
suggests that many of the welfare costs
associated with illegal immigration are
due to current birthright citizenship
policy they say greater efforts at
barring illegal aliens from federal
welfare programs do not reduce cost
because the kids are still American
citizens nationwide forty percent of the
illegal alien headed households received
some type of welfare in some states the
rate is higher in New York forty-nine
percent receive welfare in California 48
percent only 19 percent of households
headed by native
born citizens make use of a major
welfare program in other words illegal
aliens who have American citizen
children are taking advantage of welfare
at exorbitant rates and states offer
additional welfare benefits as well this
is all according to the Center for
Immigration Studies again the LA County
Supervisor estimates that illegal
immigration and birthright citizenship
cost taxpayers in LA County over a
billion dollars annually not including
education costs a lot a lot of money 59%
of illegal aliens and their us-born
children live in or near poverty and
again then these kids are able to
sponsor their parents for residency in
the United States so there's a lot of
talk today about this is racist this is
the Trump administration trying to
simply bar people who are differently
colored from coming into the United
States no there are serious economic
costs associated with low income people
and low and poorly educated folks who
are illegally immigration and illegal
immigrating to the United States coming
here having babies their kids become
citizens and now their kids are entitled
to all of the benefits that American
citizenship confers so President Trump
suggested today that he could change all
of this by executive order here's what
he said he said it was always told to me
they needed a constitutional amendment
guess what you don't and then he said
you definitely can do it with an act of
Congress but now they're saying I can do
it with just an executive order we're
the only country in the world where a
person comes in and has a baby and the
baby is essentially a citizen of the
United States with all of those benefits
it's ridiculous ridiculous and it has to
end okay so there are a couple of
contentions that he makes here
contention number one birthright
citizenship is bad policy I tend to
agree with this I think the birthright
citizenship is bad policy if you just
coming across the border and having a
baby in the United States that does not
mean that you have come in through our
legal immigration system and your
children are going to be much more
impacted obviously by their parents than
they're going to be impacted simply by
force and dint of living in the United
States so if you're interested in a
country that assimilates people to
American values you need people
immigrating legally and then having
babies here legally
now listen legal residents of the United
States different story because legal
residents very often are preparing to
become immigrants to the United States
so my in-laws for example were legal
residents to the United States my wife
came here as a child she came here back
and
until she was 12 they came here
permanently when she was 12 she did not
become an American citizen in the United
States until actually after we were
married and not because we were married
but because her her time of waiting had
expired
that was basically when she was 21 22
years old she got her American
citizenship because she had to wait 10
years in order to get American
citizenship but her younger brother was
born in the United States and he was an
American citizen as he should have been
his parents were legal residents of the
United States the 14th amendment
essentially guarantees that if you are
legal residents of the United States or
a citizen of the United States your
children are American citizens which
again makes a fair bit of sense because
if you want to make sure that kids are
ensconced in the American Way of life
you want to make sure that their parents
are loyal to the United States
government and are loyal to the American
Constitution the same is not true for
the children of illegal immigrants if
you just come across the border have a
baby never go through the legal process
we didn't want you right I mean there's
no evidence that we wanted you maybe we
do want you but we don't know there's no
evidence of this then suggesting that
this inherently is is a good idea is is
kind of foolhardy president Trump says
that we're the only country in the world
where a person comes in and has a baby
and the baby is a citizen of the United
States that's not true there are 30
countries across the world that have
birthright citizenship most of those
happen to be in Central and South
America Cuba Haiti these are places with
birthright citizenship he is not wrong
however that in the developed world we
are almost unique and I say almost I
mean the only other country that has
anything remotely like a birthright
citizenship category is Canada so Canada
has sort of a birthright citizenship
category as well no country in Europe
does so for all the talk about Europe
being open and welcoming to immigrants
the United States is birthright
citizenship policy is significantly more
open than the European policy if you
come in from Morocco to France you have
a baby in France that does not make your
citizen an actual citizen of friends you
have to apply for a legal citizenship in
France so the key phrase here in the
14th amendment is subject to the
jurisdiction thereof here's what the
14th Amendment says and you're seeing a
lot of folks in the media who don't know
anything about constitutional law whoa
pine on these issues suggest that the
14th amendment
dictates that children of illegal
immigrants are by necessity under the
Constitution citizens of the United
States that is not clear nor is it
correct I think under the text of the
Fourteenth Amendments and the Fourteenth
Amendment says this all persons born or
naturalized in the United States and
subject to the jurisdiction thereof our
citizens of the United States and of the
state will and of the State wherein they
reside that key phrase is subject to the
jurisdiction thereof again I'll read it
again all persons born or naturalized in
the United States and subject to the
jurisdiction thereof our citizens of the
United States and of the State wherein
they reside why is that phrase necessary
if you're just reading that why do you
need the phrase subject to the
jurisdiction thereof why not just all
persons born or naturalized in the
United States are citizens of the United
States obviously the phrase comes to add
something what does the phrase come to
add what does the phrase subject to the
jurisdiction there I've come to add well
the people who framed this amendment
knew what it came to add it was to
prevent a situation where a foreign
diplomat comes to the United States the
Ambassador from France comes to the
United States and his wife has a baby
and now the baby is an American citizen
not only that it was meant to prevent
citizenship for Native American tribes
because we were trying to ensure that
Native American babies born to Native
American tribes
we're not automatically American
citizens because that would be taking
sovereignty from the Native American
tribes the same thing was true of
soldiers who were fighting from abroad
in the United States so let's say there
was a mercenary force that came to the
United States someone brought along
their wives that are fighting the United
States government there but their wives
had babies in the United States it was
meant to exclude that why because they
were not subject to the jurisdiction of
the United States government meaning
that if you were subject to the
jurisdiction of another government you
are not subject to the jurisdiction of
the American government elias shapiro of
the cato institute points out again the
phrases originally written to exclude
the children of native american tribes
from american citizenship as well as the
children of foreign diplomats and
soldiers from abroad fighting on
american land the amendment itself the
14th amendment was specifically designed
to reverse Dred Scott there's an awful
evil Supreme Court case in which an
escaped slave named Dred Scott sued for
his American citizenship he said I am an
American citizen I was born in the
United States I was freed I escaped my
masters I'm now in the north and now I'm
free I'm not gonna be returned to
slavery and it abrogates my rights to be
returned to slavery in Dred Scott the
Supreme Court in evil fashion found that
the Constitution of the United States
did not apply to black people born in
the United States because they were not
covered by the Constitution the forge
amendment was designed to reverse that
and say that if you were a freed slave
if you're a black person born in the
United States than you were a citizen of
the United States Senator Jacob Howard
Republican of Michigan explained the
purpose of the subject to the
jurisdiction thereof provision back when
it was written he said this will not of
course include persons born in the
United States who are foreigners aliens
who belong to the families of
ambassadors or foreign ministers
accredited to the government of the
United States but will include every
other class of persons it settles the
great question of citizenship and
removes all doubt as to what persons are
or are not citizens of the United States
well in just a second we'll get to the
Supreme Court jurisprudence on this
which kind of muddies the issue more
than the amendment actually does from
the very outset we'll talk about that in
just second first let's talk about the
fact we're all gonna plotz the fact
we're all gonna plotz means that you got
to prepare for that eventuality if
you're not you're not being a
responsible human got a family to take
care of
there are funeral expenses you're not
gonna be earning the same way you were
before you were dead just a fact of life
unfortunately so you need life insurance
life insurance is just something that it
is responsible to have having life
insurance is a pretty good feeling
because you know at least that your
family is secure and policy genius helps
you get it it's the easy way to get life
insurance online in just two minutes you
can compare quotes from the top insurers
to find the best policy for you and when
you compare quotes you save money it is
indeed that simple policy genius has
helped over 4 million people shop for
insurance placed over twenty billion
dollars in coverage and they don't just
make life insurance easy they also
compared disability insurance and auto
insurance and home insurance if you care
about it they can cover it so if you've
been avoiding getting life insurance
because it's difficult or confusing give
policy genius a try go to policy genius
com get your quotes apply in minutes you
can do the whole thing on your phone
right now
policy genius is indeed the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance again
policy genius.com go check them out
right now let me know we sent you policy
genius the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance ok so the Supreme Court
has weighed in on birthright citizenship
kind of but not really what I mean by
this is there's a line of cases with
regards to citizenship that don't
actually clarify the issue with regard
to children of illegal immigrants so
here's the line of cases in 1884 there
was a Supreme Court case called elk vs.
Watkins I believe in which the Supreme
Court ruled that a Native American born
under the jurisdiction of a Native
American tribe could not you know add
really make himself a citizen of the
United States so what happened is there
was a baby who's born to a Native
American family under Native American
tribal sovereignty he said listen I
don't want to be subject to Native
American tribal sovereignty and I was
born in the United States I'm a United
States citizen and the court said no you
don't get to make yourself a United
States citizen just because you were
born in the United States if your
parents were subject to the jurisdiction
of a foreign body namely Native American
tribes this seems to cut against
birthright citizenship for illegal
immigrants illegal immigrants are in
fact citizens of another country and
they're subject to the jurisdiction of
those other countries how do we know
this because under the Vienna
conventions if an illegal immigrant in
the United States from Mexico say
commits a crime we have an obligation
under the Vienna Convention to let him
know about his consular rights we have
to let him know that he can go to his
local consulate and that the consulate
will provide him services this was
adjudicated in a case called Midian
versus Texas when all the way to the
Supreme Court in which this guy who
murdered someone on American soil or
raped someone dr8 may have been a rape
and murder in any case he was not
informed of his right to consular access
and this was considered a violation of
his rights because he was an illegal
immigrant in the United States so this
seems very much in line with that right
this 1884 case that says just cuz you're
born in the United States if you are
subject to the jurisdiction of a foreign
power you are not a United States
citizen in 1898 there was another case
and this is the one that proponents of
birthright citizenship like to cite the
Supreme Court ruled that Wong Kim Ark
was a child born in the United States to
a legal resident Chinese immigrant
couple was included in birthright
citizenship but again that was who legal
residents that's more like the case of
my parents in law and my and my
brother-in-law and he was born in the
United States to legal resident parents
and therefore he's an American citizen
fine this was not adjudicated the
question of illegal immigrant children
was not adjudicated all the way until
1982 we're gonna talk about this ruling
which is really the only ruling on
record with regard to birthright
citizenship for illegal immigrants in
just one second so the case in 1982 is a
very famous case called Plyler v doe it
is a wrongly decided case this case made
famous by a very left Supreme Court this
case basically was about whether the
state of Texas could deny educational
benefits to children of illegal
so kids were born in the United States
they were the children of illegal
immigrants and the question was do they
actually have to be given free public
education at the cost of the state the
state of Texas said no the Supreme Court
said yes that's because it was a lift
that left his Supreme Court there's no
evidence that this is really accurate or
this is a good ruling Justice William
Brennan a very leftist judge wrote in a
foot now quote no plausible distinction
with respect to Fourteenth Amendment
jurisdiction can be drawn between
resident aliens who's entering into the
United States was lawful and resident
aliens whose entry was unlawful well
that obviously is bullcrap okay we make
distinctions along those lines all the
time all the time we are constantly
making legal distinctions between
resident aliens who came here lawfully
and resident aliens who came here
unlawfully like for example if you're a
resident alien you came here unlawfully
we can deport you right under American
law if you're a resident alien came here
lawfully we cannot deport you under
American law at least not without some
sort of violation so this is simply a
nonsense opinion now just because it's a
nonsense opinion does not mean that it
does not have some sort of legal
standing it does and the fact is that
there is legal standing for for Plyler
versus doe what that means that when
President Trump says that he can simply
issue an executive order and overrule
that Supreme Court ruling or overrule
the federal laws that have taken that
have taken precedence in order to ensure
the quote/unquote rights of children of
illegal immigrants that's not correct
an act of Congress might be able to do
it maybe not in any case it was going to
go to the Supreme Court and that's
really what this is all about President
Trump was gonna sign an executive order
and then this was gonna be litigated all
the way to the top of the Supreme Court
at which point the Supreme Court would
would rule on all this now is Trump
really going to do all of us who knows
and when I see folks on the Left who are
very very upset about Trump talking
about executive orders this way I don't
like executive orders this way either I
don't think this is what the executive
branch should be doing the executive
branch does not have the power nor does
it have the capacity to rewrite laws or
rewrite the Constitution I felt that way
about Barack Obama rewriting the laws to
simply suggest he was not going to
prosecute illegal immigrants and I don't
like it when President Trump says he can
rewrite the laws with regard to
birthright citizenship from the office
of the presidency the president is not a
king the executive branch is not a
monarchy with
that said the same folks who cheered
when President Obama said he could
unilaterally rewrite law to prevent the
deportation of millions of illegal
immigrants in the United States without
any change from Congress those same
people are suddenly finding refuge in
the Constitution and in the balance of
powers and checks and balances of the
American constitutional system I find
that somewhat ironic now what is this
really about what is this well the truth
is the president if he wants to pursue
something like this he does have a
Republican Congress he could push his
Congress for a law he does have a
Republican Senate he could push the
Senate for a law this is really about
ginning up the base in advance of the
2018 election and it ties in to what
president Trump's key argument has
always been with regard to immigration
going all the way back to 2015-2016
which is that we are far too nice about
illegal immigration in this country and
that we have to start taking measures
and steps to prevent illegal immigration
from draining the united states of
economic benefit right that's been
president Trump's contention before
legitimately years at this point it's
also connected with his rhetoric with
regard to the caravan that is coming up
through Mexico now there are a lot of
folks who are suggesting that is
rhetoric with regard to the caravan is
over the top that is rhetoric with
regard to the caravan is not accurate in
some ways it's accurate and in some ways
it's not I want to be as fair as I can
to both the president and his critics
when it comes to his treatment of this
migrant caravan the migrant caravan is
indeed a publicity stunt I mean there's
just no question that that's what it is
it's it's being promulgated and pushed
by Central American Latin American
governments it's being pushed by the
government of Mexico which is allowing
migrant caravan to travel toward the
United States border when the president
says these are not folks who are
eligible for asylum he is basically
correct asylum is for people who are
being targeted by a government it is not
for economic migrants who simply want to
cross over into the United States in
order to take advantage of the economic
benefit of living in a rich and powerful
country that's that is it an invasion
it's not an invasion when you walk up to
a point of entry and ask for asylum that
doesn't that counts as an invasion an
invasion is when you cross the border
with a gun right that's an invasion this
is not an invasion and the overwrought
rhetoric with regard to illegal
immigration is not useful you can be
against illegal immigration you can
point out the the demerits of illegal
immigration
can point out that the system is being
abused which it surely is
you can even oppose birthright
citizenship unconstitutional and and
moral grounds but what you shouldn't do
is suggest that the United States is in
imminent doom and peril from a thousand
people who are walking up to points of
entry at the southern border because
that does raised hackles in a way that
seems inaccurate you know alarmism is
not something I'm very much in favor of
on either side of the political aisle
I'm not gonna pretend I haven't engaged
in it from time to time but we need to
be at least somewhat circumspect in how
we approach these issues even though I'm
generally on president Trump's side of
the illegal immigration issue we'll talk
about that in just one second plus I
want to talk about the latest fallout
from the Pittsburgh shooting and all of
the rest but first let's talk about
Elizabeth Warren so Elizabeth Warren
turns out she's whiter than anyone
anyone on earth how do we know well
because she took a genetic test to tell
us and then she bragged about how she
might be one 1024
Native American which really meant
Peruvian or Columbian that was
interesting information you could have
similarly interesting information about
your own ancestry by going over to
23andme find out whether you're more
Native American than Elizabeth Warren
the 23andme health and ancestry service
includes reports and how your DNA can
influence your weight sleep quality
caffeine intake sense of taste whether
you're likely to be lactose intolerant
and more it's really easy to just
slobber into a tube providing your
23andme kit and you mail your saliva
sample back to the lab to be analyzed
they give you all sorts of cool
information about yourself they've got a
bitter taste report done sweet versus
salty report DNA can play a role in
determining your food preferences from
salt and from salty to sweet too bitter
and it'll tell you all about it plus the
deep sleep report now tells you if
you're more likely to be an especially
deep sleeper there's a saturated fat and
weight report telling you based on your
genetics how your weight might be
affected by saturated fats in your diet
so you know you should actually change
your diet for the better based on this
order your 23andme health an ancestry
service kit at 23andme comm slash capiro
that's the number two three-and me.com
slash Shapiro 23andme comm slash appear
I'll go check it out right now let them
know that we sent you and again find out
whether you are in fact more Native
American than Elizabeth Warren
interesting information for everyone to
have okay so let's talk about President
Trump's rhetoric with regards to illegal
immigration in the care of him because
here's where the news really meets it's
sort of Nexus right now the left is
content
that President Trump's language about
illegal immigration and about the
migrant caravan is what led to the
shooting at a Pennsylvania synagogue in
Pittsburgh the tree of life synagogue in
Pittsburgh the case that they're making
is basically a white supremacist got all
riled up about illegal immigration
because of President Trump railing
against migrants and then he went and
shot up a synagogue now suffice it to
say white supremacist have been shooting
up Jewish places of worship and Jewish
sites for as long as I can remember as I
mentioned yesterday on the show in 1991
in my community a synagogue was fire
bombed in 1999 the West Valley JCC was
shot up by white supremacists that same
year there was a shooting of Orthodox
Jews in Chicago by a white supremacist
this sort of stuff is not infrequent
it's not infrequent and it is a real
threat in the United States but I guess
the case is that he wouldn't have shot
up this particular synagogue or gone
after this particular group except that
he was very angry at the Hebrew
immigrant Aid Society which is a group
that welcomes refugees into the United
States and so if President Trump weren't
using such inflammatory rhetoric then
this shul wouldn't been targeted this
raises a couple of questions one whether
in fact his rhetoric whether
inflammatory rhetoric is connected with
violence and number two whether it's
accurate so as far as its accuracy Shep
Smith was on Fox News last night saying
there is no invasion he's getting all
sorts of plaudits from folks on the left
for saying this here was Shep sort of
railing against the the language being
used with regards to the migrant caravan
tomorrow is one week before the midterm
election which is what all of this is
about there is no invasion no one's
coming to get you there's nothing at all
to worry about when they did this now
the question is whether people really
believe whether whether people really
believe that when Trump says there's an
invasion taking place whether he means
this in sort of generalized fashion
meaning that waves of illegal immigrants
are coming across the border thousands
at a time and that this is having an
impact on our culture it's having an
impact on our economics it's having an
impact on our labor force or whether
they actually believe the most
inflammatory version of this which is
that they're legitimately people who are
coming in to destroy the United States
with the ill intent I'm not a fan of
this sort of rhetoric of invasion
because I don't actually think that
illegal immigrants
invading the country I think they're
people who are coming here for the most
part to work that doesn't mean we have
to accept them it doesn't mean that it's
in the United States is interest to
simply allow people to cross the border
illegally but I don't I'm not fond of
this sort of rhetoric you know the sort
of scare tactics that people are
bringing in criminality and disease like
we actually have to look at the
statistics and see whether that is true
or not
with that said with that said I am
deeply worried that people are
connecting rhetoric to violence in a way
that actually risks censorship so the
let's let's be frank about the
connection between rhetoric and violence
it is true that speech is related to
action it is you listen to my show
presumably if you agree with me you are
now more likely to get involved in
politics in a way that I would agree
with that's why I do the show every day
I'm trying to get people to think in a
different way or to examine the issues a
little bit differently and that's normal
that's the way politics works we do it
every day with our children we do it
every day with our friends with our
co-workers with our spouses speech is
related to action with that set the
attempts by folks on the left to connect
every action of speech with violence and
to suggest that speech is connected with
violence is a way of shutting down
speech of course more nasty rhetoric is
more likely to create more nasty action
that is a question really of us being
circumspect but I really don't think
that that's what we ought to be debating
in in the how we speak question first of
all I will note that the left's utter
refusal to acknowledge that the left
hasn't been in any way responsible any
way responsible for the heightening of
rhetoric over the past 10 years is
that's irresponsible that's
irresponsible not only is it
irresponsible it's polarizing and it
actually leads to radicalization radical
rhetoric leads to radicalization you
know what else leads to radicalization
being called a radical by the other side
unjustifiably that also leads to
radicalization well we've got right now
is everybody pointing fingers at
everybody else and nobody looking at
themselves and saying okay what can I do
to change the tenor and climate of the
political debate and what the left has
been doing with regard to Trump's talk
on caravans and migrants has been saying
well Trump is causing violence I don't
actually think that's the biggest
problem with what President Trump is
doing and the same thing is true on the
left when Bernie Sanders says millions
will die because Republic
health care I don't think that the big
problem with that is that somebody is
gonna go and shoot up a congressional
baseball game I don't hope Bernie
Sanders responsible for that I think the
problem with the these sort of radical
polarized rhetoric the kind of inflamed
rhetoric the problem with that sort of
thing is that when something terrible
does happen when somebody does something
that is truly evil when somebody goes
and shoots up a synagogue for example
instead of us unifying and saying all of
that is bad we are now more likely to
see the other side as responsible for a
crime that we all agree is evil the
social fabric relies on us looking at
each other as though we are friends and
not enemies but if our politics is all
about how we are enemies and when
something bad happens the first reaction
is to blame it on your enemy and when
that happens the social fabric actually
decays that's the biggest problem that I
see here you know when Cass Sunstein he
writes a piece for Bloomberg today and
when she says that Trump's hateful
speech raises the risk of violence the
the one-sided focus on president Trump's
speech as opposed to the left speech is
counterproductive if we want to say
let's all take it down and let's all
take it down a notch this I agree with
but if you want to say that Trump is
uniquely responsible for the tone and
tenor of American political debate right
now that's just not accurate it's just
not accurate and you know it's not
accurate
I mean legitimately in the last 24 hours
a Republican Party headquarters in
volusia county in florida the the
windows were shot out here's footage
from that just walked in they come in
through the back door and they saw the
windows and did not have time at that
point to look around and then i didn't
realize there was gunfire but there's
four bullet holes in our window
and there's four bullet holes inside the
building okay so the idea that violent
rhetoric is only happening on one side
is just a life there's another problem
with suggesting that rhetoric is is
deeply connected with violence and that
is a compulsion to censorship so there
is a threat in saying that rhetoric is
directly connected with violence here's
the threat the threat is that people
will then say okay let's restrict the
rhetoric let's restrict the rhetoric and
that's the move that's being made in for
example Europe it's being made I'm right
now I'm broadcasting from Vancouver it's
a move that's being made in Canada in
Europe and there's a case that's being
wildly under under covered in Europe
there's an amazing amazing case in which
a woman was fined for criticizing the
Prophet Mohammed hey this is this is the
the description of the case from the
Atlantic Grimwood writes a few years ago
I appeared on a live Egyptian television
show hosted by a conservative Muslim
with jihadist sympathies he lured me on
by offering to answer any question I had
about Islam including he said whether
the president whether the Prophet
Mohammed was a child molester the host
seemed awfully open-minded I thought
given how humorless jihadists tend to be
about the Prophet when the lights went
up and the program began I mentioned the
child molester issue the host remained
true to his word
neither bursting interracial art writing
me for my impertinence around the same
time a woman referred to as es was
convicted in Austria for in effect not
phrasing her identical curiosity in the
form of a question on Thursday the
European Court of Human Rights upheld
her 2011 conviction for disparagement of
religious precepts a crime in Austria
the facts of what yes did are not in
dispute
she held seminars in which he presented
her view that Mohammed was indeed a
child molester
dominant Islamic traditions hold that
Muhammad's third wife Aisha was six at
the time of their marriage and nine at
its consummation Muhammad was in his
early 50s the Austrian woman repeated
these claims the Austrian Court ruled
she had to pay 480 euros are spending 60
days in jail and the ECHR ruled Austria
had not violated her rights this is the
consequence of restricting speech
because you believe that speech either
leads to violence or is violence there
are consequences on the other side of
this equation it's not all about
rhetoric and violence are connected
therefore take down the rhetoric there
is a problem with saying rhetoric and
violence are connected and therefore we
must restrict the rhetoric so let's be
very careful about what it is that we
are calling for here we have to be very
careful because well not
careful then the impact of that is going
to be a lot worse than the actual
disease itself okay in just a second I
want to talk about anti-semitism about
the media's radical rhetoric we're gonna
get to all of that in just one second
but first let's talk about the software
that your company uses when you're
dealing with a real head-scratcher about
which software to use you need a go-to
person on call but when it comes to
software those people are software
advice when it comes to picking the
right software for your business
software advice is done all the research
for you their team of advisors can point
you in the right direction so you can
start working more effectively right now
and it's absolutely free just go to
software advice.com slash Ben you answer
a few short questions about your
business you're connected with an
advisor to discuss the best software
options for your needs you can talk to
an advisor it's like 10 minutes or less
it doesn't matter what profession you
are in you need better software okay
you're still using like Excel 1997
that's not going to cut it you need
something better if you're an
entrepreneur if you work solo software
advice is a great way to get an expert
opinion even without the resources of a
big company so n the software struggle
right now go to software advice.com
slash Ben to get started these experts
are ready to be your on-call go-to team
right now that software advice.com slash
Ben connects with an advisor for free
again that software advice.com slash
been talking to an advisor takes just
ten minutes and you can make your
business significantly more efficient
with pretty much a simple phone call go
to software advice.com slash Ben right
now go check it out okay so I do want to
talk about the the one-sidedness of the
media's rhetoric talk because again I
think that that is actually exacerbating
the divisions in our society in an
extraordinarily serious way I talk about
all of that you're gonna have to
subscribe over at daily wire comm all
you have to do is go over to daily wear
comm $9.99 a month gets you the
subscription you see the rest of my show
live Darcy Andrew Clavin show by the
rest of Michael Noel's show live plus
you get the latest episode of another
kingdom early so we have this amazing
new kind of animated series or
Illustrated series it's based on Andrew
Cravens book another kingdom he's in the
second volume Michael Mills reads it and
believe it or not isn't bad at what he
does so go check that out the visuals
are really beautiful and you can get
that if you subscribe you can't get it
until Friday in audio version you can't
really get it all visually until you
subscribe so go check it out right now
for $9.99 a month also for $99 a year
you get this the very greatest and
beverage vessels see it here in my hand
of course you
because when I'm on the road it goes
invisible that's one of the great things
about the leftist chairs hot or cold
tumbler you don't have to worry about
security because you just hit the button
on the back end boom it's gone and then
it reappears as soon as I got back to my
studio in Los Angeles you get all of
those things for $99 a year also please
subscribe over to iTunes or YouTube
leave us a review it really does help us
over night UN's 5-star reviews are the
only ones that are accepted you want to
help us in the rankings you want to help
us defeat all the other podcasts in the
rankings be victorious then you have to
leave us a five-star review go check
that out also this week we have an
amazing Sunday special tucker carlson
stopped by it's so good it's gonna be so
good so go check that out
right now we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
I want to talk about the polarization
and one of the reasons that lying about
the level of rancor on the other side
while whitewashing yourself is a bad
idea I have two kids right I have a kid
who's four and a half M kid who's two
and a half the four and a half year old
is just a wonderful beautiful girl she
definitely stands up for herself the two
and a half year old has now decided he's
had enough and so he's going to harass
her every waking minute of every single
day and we as parents have to decide
exactly how we're going to treat this
now the easy response is that when he
pushes her and she screams in his face
which is basically every hour or two in
our house right now - I simply punish
him or do I punish her also the answer
is what I do is I say to him you need to
go in her crib right now
right you get a timeout you're not know
how to push her sister and I say to her
Leah when you have a problem I need you
to come and talk to me about it I need
you to I need you to actually talk to me
I'm standing right here you don't need
to scream in his face there's an
authority figure for - - which you can
appeal and screaming in his face or
pushing him back is not the proper
solution to this problem now he's he
more responsible than she is you bet of
course she of course he is right he's
pushing her but that doesn't mean that
she gets to act like a brat she doesn't
it to scream in his face
she doesn't it to push him back
shouldn't get to do any of those things
right now in American politics here's
how things are going people on the Left
see themselves as my daughter people on
the right see themselves as my daughter
everybody feels like they are being
pushed by the other side and they feel
like it's okay to scream back in that
person's face nobody is saying yeah I'm
being pushed by the other side and
that's bad but also I shouldn't scream
in anybody's face and push back maybe
what I should do instead is appeal to
the broader of moral authority of the
American people and not act like this
you know the media have been saying for
a long time president Trump needs to
stop saying the press are the enemy of
the people now President Trump I got a
lot of blowback yesterday because I
tweeted out that President Trump should
not say that the media are the enemy of
the people a lot of folks on the right
say no no no he means the fake news are
the enemy of the people I would buy that
narrative except that President Trump
has never been very clear about what
constitutes the fake news now there's
stuff I think is fake news right there
are people who are according for
journalists who are actually just
opinion makers there are actual
headlines that are wrong that stuff is
fake news but the president has been a
blunderbuss in his use of the term fake
news if there's a poll he doesn't like
it's fake news if there's a story that
he doesn't like it's fake news he's
never actually been very good about
objectively saying what his fake news
and what is not so I'm not gonna buy
that exact excuse me the press though
say you know the president shouldn't say
that Trump Trump shouldn't say that the
press are the enemy of the people that's
true also true the media should not
portray President Trump as the enemy of
the people which they have been doing
literally since the day he was elected
and before they say he is a Russian
agent they say that he's a traitor to
the country they say that he's doing all
of this for his own personal enrichment
without any evidence to this point they
say all of these things and then they
think okay well our hands are clean our
hands are clean and you can see the sort
of attitude you want to know why folks
are angry at the media on the right this
is one of the reasons the folks are
angry at the media on the right here's
Jim Acosta going after Sarah Huckabee
Sanders on this basis you a state for
the record which outlets that you and
the president regard as the enemy of the
people I mean the president is going to
say the think news media are the enemy
of the people and if you're going to
stand there and continue to say that
there are some journalists some news
outlets in this country that meet that
that characterization shouldn't you have
the guts Sarah to state which outlets
which journalists are the enemy of the
people okay
and really what she should say is I mean
what Trump thinks is you Jim Acosta
reppin that that's what's obviously
running through Sarah Huckabee Sanders
his head
she's stuck between a rock and a hard
place because as the press secretary you
don't want to start labeling people
enemy of the people it's why Trump
shouldn't be using the phrase but if
you're gonna talk about fake news right
I mean I think that Jim Acosta is is not
a good journalist I think just as
objectively speaking as I can be I think
Jim Acosta loves him some Jim Acosta he
sees himself as an activist more than
its journalist and it's obvious to
everyone CNN then tweeted out in
response to Sarah Huckabee Sanders who
said that the that Sarah B Sanders went
after the media she said you guys are
polarizing the debate because you're
suggesting that President Trump is
responsible for shootings and bombings
CNN communications said no press
secretary CNN did not say Donald Trump
was directly responsible for the bomb
sent to our office by his ardent and
embolden supporter we did say that he
and you should understand her words--
matter every single one of them but so
you don't seem to get that okay it's a
lie CNN has been saying for a week for a
week that Trump should be taking
responsibility for the bombing I mean I
read you the Chiron's like last week for
a full segment and CNN then host people
like Julia Joffe is this radical
journalist quote unquote journalists
from GQ who went on CNN yesterday and
then said that Trump radicalizes more
people than Isis does this president has
radicalized so many more people than
Isis ever did I mean the way he talks
the way he the way he had is that just
it's it's the way he talks the way the
way that he allows these the way he
winks and nods to these groups the way
he says I know I'm not supposed to
that's what she says right there isn't
saying it's so insane she actually had
to come back and quasi apologized for
but let's not pretend that the heated
rhetoric and the escalation of moral
calumny on the other side that that
hasn't taken place on both sides because
it absolutely has okay in just one
second I want to talk about
anti-semitism because I think that
there's a deeper debate to be had right
now in the wake of the Pittsburgh
shooting about what anti-semitism is and
what's driving anti-semitism on the far
right and on the mainstream left because
it really is this right okay it's not
the mainstream right that is embraced
anti-semitism it is the mainstream left
which is embrace to keith Ellison and
Linda Sarsour has embraced BDS has
embraced an anti-israel position that
amounts to anti-semitism not every
opposition to Israeli policy is
anti-semitism i've been i've opposed
many Israeli policies but that does not
amount to anti-semitism what does if
you're embracing policies that lead to
the destruction of the Jewish state and
you don't care about that right that is
embracing the boycott the best sanctions
regime for example that is anti-semitism
if you want the Jewish state to be
destroyed by treating it like it unlike
any other state on planet earth then
this means that you're engaged in
anti-semitism but the left and the right
see anti-semitism as two very different
things and I'm not even sure it's a
left-right divide I think that it's a
correctly understanding anti-semitism
versus not correctly an understanding
anti-semitism divide here are the two
ways of seeing anti-semitism one
anti-semitism is unique evil and world
history it is not like any other form of
bigotry anti-semitism is based on a
generalized conspiracy theory
whereby anything that happens in the
world that is bad is the responsibility
of the Jews so if you are a capitalist
and
don't like the Communists it's because
the Communists are Jews that you really
have a problem and if you're a communist
and you don't like capitalists the real
problem is Goldman Sachs and all those
Jews who are at the top of the heap and
if you are an internationalist and you
don't like nationalism well it's those
evil Jews in Israel who are responsible
for the breakdown in the global order
and if you are nationalists who doesn't
like internationalism
it's the globalist cuck Jews who are
responsible for everything in the world
in other words anti-semitism is a is a
solution to every problem for the
conspiracy minded person the Jews are
responsible for everything anti-semitism
is based on the idea that there is this
powerful nefarious group that is running
things undermining your society and that
is why anti-semitism is so chameleon ik
it's so changeable right racism against
black folks has basically taken one form
in the United States saying that black
folks are inferior right that's really
what racism in the United States has
been about against black folks and it's
evil it's evil but a conspiracy theory
about folks running the world is a
different sort of evil than in evil that
says that people are genetically
inferior and not the same thing
so theory number one is that
anti-semitism is a unique evil in world
history where you attribute everything
bad happening in the universe to the
Jews and in essence anti-semitism is
sort of an anti God position because if
you're a god based person what you
believe is that the world is the way
that God made it and the Jews are not
responsible for the world the way that
God made it if you are anti God then you
say okay the group respect I have to
look for some nefarious force behind
world events that will be the Jews and
this is the the thread that holds true
whether you are whether you're talking
about Christian anti-semitism during the
Crusades it's the Jews who are
undermining our society because they
killed Christ or they're talking about
Islamic anti-semitism today it's the
Jews who are behind the State of Israel
and who are the sons of dogs and pigs
and monkeys and they're manipulating
world events against us it's behind Nazi
anti-semitism and communist
anti-semitism this generalized
conspiracy theory and it gets violent
because if you believe the Jews have
power then that means the Jews must be
stopped that's what drove this white
supremacists in Pittsburgh and if you
look at his speed it was all about the
Jews have too much power the Jews must
be stopped
so anti-semitism is a difference in kind
not just a difference in degree in the
second theory of anti-semitism is that
all anti-semitism is just basically a
small version of generalized bigotry
bigotry comes in all forms anti-semitism
is just bigotry against Jews that sort
of the perspective that Barack Obama was
pushing in the aftermath of the shooting
in Pittsburgh he said we grieve for the
Americans murdered in Pittsburgh all of
us have to fight the rise of
anti-semitism and hateful rhetoric
against those who look love or pray
differently okay so the idea is here
that anti-semitism is just another
iteration of intersectional racism but
basically there's this dominant society
that hates minority groups choose our
minority group and that's why the
dominant society hates them the first
version of anti-semitism suggests that
America is a success story because
America is the most tolerant country for
Jews in history in world history except
for the State of Israel itself is the
most tolerant country for Jews ever
write it so that means that America is a
success story specifically because
America does not see this grave ill that
is plaguing the world as the Jews or
anything like that that speaks to
America's bastion of Liberty the version
of anti-semitism as a sort of subset of
generalized bigotry in that version of
anti-semitism that really suggests that
the that America is a bad place because
even if the United States is different
it's only different because the Jews are
white the reason that anti-semitism
isn't bad in the United States is
because Jews are more powerful and they
are higher on the intersectional
hierarchy of power than other groups
now what this leads to on the left is a
belief that anti-semitism is actually
less important than other forms of
bigotry specifically because the left
sees all bigotry has rooted in
hierarchies of power so if Jews are
powerful if Jews are rich if Jews are
tolerated in the United States that
means anti-semitism is less important
than other forms of bigotry and that
means that you can attribute Jewish
success not to freedom and that's the
good of the United States that's the
good of the world instead you can
attribute lack of anti-semitism to Jews
gaining power themselves because Jews
can actually be outstripped in the
intersectional hierarchy by other forms
of racism and so the intersectional
version of what anti-semitism is
actually can lead to more anti-semitism
because what it suggests is if the Jews
escaped anti-semitism if the Jews
succeed in Israel
if the Jews succeed in the United States
that is an effect of them climbing that
intersectional power hi
Archy and thus leaving behind their
membership in the group victimhood clan
and the group victimhood clique and this
is why the left-wing version of
anti-semitism is not only wrong it is
actually counterproductive and leads to
more anti-semitism and has been
mainstreamed into the Democratic Party
today it's it's actually a grave grave
problem understanding anti-semitism is
the key to fighting it and I fear that a
lot of folks don't actually understand
what anti-semitism is or if they do
they're ignoring it okay time for a
quick thing I like and then a thing that
I hate and then we'll be out of here so
things that I like yeah I sort of pine
for attained American when our ideals
were the same our ideals used to be that
if you came to the United States to
engage in the in the freedoms and
liberties provided by the United States
Constitution if you came here and you
embraced what we were then you were then
you were part of our country and this
has always been sort of my guiding light
I've said a thousand times really a
thousand times the people who are born
in the United States who don't believe
in the foundational ideals of the United
States I would trade those folks for
people who live outside the United
States and who want to come in and join
those ideals in a heartbeat because
ideals matter to me a lot more than
where you were born ideals matter to me
race doesn't matter to me ethnicity
doesn't matter to me ideals matter to me
this used to be what everyone agreed on
left and right and now it seems like
it's being abandoned on the left and in
response some on the right are
abandoning it too and that's really
gross and terrible when I say the folks
on the Left used to embrace this you
know Frank Sinatra
was you know a mainstream member of
Hollywood he was a JFK supporter
obviously who's Roosevelt support well
during World War two very end of World
War two the the studio's cut a 10-minute
little movie with a very very young
Frank Sinatra called the house I live in
and it was basically a an ode to what
America should be and the plot of this
little 10-minute movie is basically
there's a Jewish kid in neighborhood and
kids start taunting him and chasing him
and Frank Sinatra stops them from
taunting and chasing a Jewish kid and
then he sings a song called the house I
live in this was the closing number for
Sinatra for years he believed that this
was what America was all about here's a
little bit of the house I live in which
was written by real leftists real
leftist in the United States who still
believed in the at least aspirational
ideal
America's people could all live together
if we abided by certain notions of
freedom and liberty what is America a
name a man a flag I see a certain world
democracy what is America
our house I live in
a plumber Street grocer and the butcher
and the people that I meet the children
in the playground the faces that I see
all races and religions that's America
and playing the whole thing but it's you
know it's worth listening to again there
was a time in America where we all sort
of agreed on this stuff but apparently
that time is long gone in favor of
intersectional identity politics on one
end and then what and then a sort of
responsive reactionary identity politics
on the other okay time for a couple of
things that I hate okay so thing number
one that I hate so I don't know what
Hollywood is doing I really don't know
so apparently there is a new movie
that's going to come out about a story
of a refugee from Syria who is trying to
or I guess she was fleeing Egypt and she
was trying to flee Egypt for Sweden and
she was shipwrecked along the way and
she basically held her two small
children as she was shipwrecked so
Steven Spielberg and JJ Abrams are Co
producing this movie and they have
tapped Lena Dunham to write this Lena
Dunham even folks on the left are going
on what like why is Lena Dunham doing
that like why did they tap Lena Dunham
part it just shows you that if you're on
the left there's no such thing as a
national talent judgement it's pretty
amazing I mean you're you're you're
pretty much able to get away with with
virtually anything unless mean Lena
Dunham has a very very poor track record
in public from abandoned from allegedly
abandoning dogs so the stuff that she
wrote in her autobiography about
molesting her sister you know she's
still getting shots in Hollywood because
everyone gets a shot in Hollywood so
long as you are of the proper as long as
you're of the proper political
persuasion so that's that's pretty bad
stuff and then people wonder why
Hollywood has out of touch with
Hollywood is deeply deeply out of touch
obviously okay well you know I've talked
a lot about things that I just like
today so I think I'm gonna I'm gonna
stop it there we're in Vancouver tonight
I'm speaking a Jewish community event
tonight I'm speaking at the University
of British Columbia tomorrow so we have
a lot of big events coming up I'm really
looking forward to talking here and
hopefully not getting arrested so that
that'll be my goal here is to say as
many true things as I can without
getting arrested because hey this is
Canada it's like the upside down right
here it's weird but well we'll be back
tomorrow with all the updates I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire Ford
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018